listening  most people are terrible listeners in  the very narrow context of podcasting so  many hosts they're not listening to  their guests they're just waiting to ask  the next question or or they're just  biting their time until they can tell  their story about their take on  something it's it's about being present  right are you actually listening to the  people that you're engaging with during  the day that's definitely  uh something that I still need a lot of  work on I'm busy and I'm trying to get  from one place to the next and I don't  really want to sit and listen to what  somebody's trying to tell me when I'm  perceiving them to be like an obstacle  to where I'm actually going right so I  think it's inextricably linked with  trying to be in the moment if you can  Master listening you're already going to  be way ahead in just about everything  important in life